okay we're still fighting about the last
segments just so you know but I'm still
fighting I'm furious all right never
serious concerns though over flying in
Joe Biden's America a number of scary
close calls with planes almost smashing
into each other on runways and other
dangerous situations leaving passengers
on the edge of their seats some of them
hitting the top of the plane but that's
another issue the problem is so bad that
the FAA held its first emergency safety
Summit in 14 years to address it fear
not though our secretary of incompetence
is on the case by pretending to be a
pilot
we have seen an uptick in Runway
incursions and close calls something
that we are not going to allow to turn
into something worse before we come
together we'll never take for granted
the extraordinary safety record in U.S
Aviation and we're going to continue
doing everything that we can to ensure
that the U.S Remains the gold standard
when it comes to Aviation safety and
this isn't very reassuring Republicans
are ripping Joe Biden for pushing a guy
to run the Federal Aviation
Administration who has absolutely no
flying experience now you know what I
yet the truth is Brian that I think
America is like tired of people being
selected for positions based on identity
politics here's a guy who was in the
Army good for him but he was on the
ground not in the air okay and they he's
never been a pilot he's never been
involved in it in in any kind of
Aviation experience and yet they want
him to run the FAA at a time when
nobody's on time and people are crashing
into each other on the runways the
problem is if the Democrats don't buy
the argument that he's not qualified and
he's not especially compared to the
other ones he's got to get through
because it's for it's 5149 and they have
the advantage in the committee it's
going to go to the general floor he's
going to get passed but his name is Phil
Washington sounds like a great guy but
he's the CEO of the Denver International
Airport for a couple of months uh that's
it and at a time in which we have way
too many close calls that even be Buddha
judge would admit he's a little
disturbed by it uh it's not the time for
a rookie of the FAA but I would like to
have somebody there the other thing I
thought the people at a judge said I
think one of the problems is we asked a
lot of people to retire they took the
buyouts and he goes we have kind of a
rust a kind of a rust like the whole
flying things yeah the pandemic we're a
little rusty one year we get rusty we're
not good at flying anymore we should all
get helmets and just hope for the best
yeah or get some kind of pad for your
head Jesse what about the fact that I
mean this guy Buddha judge I mean he
says we want to continue continue to
raise the bar so our Aviation system
Remains the gold standard in aviation is
he stupid yeah he's dumb but in
everything he touches dies look what
happened with shipping look what
happened with trains and now he's
messing with the planes you don't mess
with the planes I see the guy in the
cockpit first thing I think of is a joke
second thing I think of is another joke
third thing I think of is that plane's
going down and it's going down hard and
that's not a joke this guy that they're
nominating Washington he dropped out of
high school then he ran the LA transit
authority and a whistleblower blew the
whistle on him because he was taking
Kickbacks and then he went and remember
to be the CEO of the Denver Airport do
you know what the CEO of the airport
does they manage the Chick-fil-A in the
restaurants they manage the restaurants
they have nothing to do with flying at
all and now he's gonna be in charge of
all the planes not crashing into each
other I think we could do better why is
this Administration Herald putting
ideology before the American people us
well I'm not sure that I would I'm
settled on that view that that's what
they're doing I I think I think a couple
things um I like everybody I'm concerned
that for for years I was in Congress
from 96 to 2006 and there were things we
should have been doing to fund the FAA
then and some help modernize their
infrastructure be it the the way we
train air traffic controllers to the
equipment that they use to the systems
that they that the technology that they
use and we should upgrade all of that
and we shouldn't we normally wait in
government so there's a catastrophe to
do it two I don't know Phil Washington I
know he served almost 25 years in the
United States Army uh and I didn't the
things that you've shared there Jesse I
didn't know those things you don't know
a lot of notes
I do I do think it's important you go
before a committee and they ask you
probing questions what I saw
unfortunately in his situation was that
it was GOP Pilots at least I did read
the fact sheet this time yeah I've read
them all the time I think you'll get
better information
at least different
you get only GOP pilots in and the GOP
Senators have raised questions and
everybody write the race questions and
he has every right to provide answers I
do hope that if they can't come to
consensus and they can't pass him that
they do nominate someone who can get in
that position because we need we need
people in that position now people see
about qualifications James Baker in my
estimate is one of the great Statesman
this country has ever had as secretary
of state Secretary of Treasury now I'm
not sure he was qualified for all those
jobs but he he had a he had a set of
values he had a sense of the job and he
knew how to lead so if this guy knows
how to lead in 25 years in the military
to me is a is a metaphor since that
maybe he does know how to lead in some
ways rising to the rank of major but if
he can't do it if he don't have the
votes they should put someone else in
the job
in 25 years in the military is an
indication he could lead then why is he
running Chick-fil-A at the airport he's
not running Chick-fil-A okay I've spent
a lot of time at the Denver
International Airport it's a great
airport they have a wonderful United
Club I want to give them a big shout out
so well done there Jesse's right don't
mess the planes you know we we cannot
have tragedies we've had so many
near-misses yeah so many near collisions
on Airport runways and you know planes
essentially dropping out of the sky
we're very lucky that the pilots were
competent enough to bring them back up
before they crashed into the ocean uh
severe turbulence a lot of this does go
on the shoulders of Pete footage Edge
because we don't have an FAA
administrator right now and can someone
this in this Administration please have
experience you know to your point you
don't have to have this specific
experience but you certainly need
confidence and there is a deartha in
this Administration right now between
the vice president the Secretary of
Transportation the Secretary of Energy
you know she was just saying like China
is a model for green energy and they're
amazing it's like
on that one we need leadership and and
we're not getting it but that I had a
magic wand that we could grab more oil
remember that one and the overlapping
yes yeah laughing is a part of the uh
exercise hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else